[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans si on
parlait sport sur TV 78 l'émission à ne
surtout pas manquer si vous êtes un
passionné de sport local aujourd'hui
comme toujours il y aura des analyses
techniques des décryptages et surtout
une dose de bonne humeur pour
m'accompagner nos chroniqueurs sont avec
nous sur ce plateau et ils sont osseux
ils se sont préparés comme jamais pour
cette émission présentation en musique
de cette magnifique dream team on
commence à ma droite musique tout le
monde le disait en 2022 et tout le monde
continue à le dire en 2023 les fans
disent que c'est jaune entre George
Clooney et Russell Crow il nous vient
tout droit des contrées versaillesse
notre gladiateur Pierre Chevalier
responsable communication Rugby Club de
Versailles avec nous pendant une heure
Dany bonjour que donneur encore pour
cette bonne résolution toujours un
plaisir d'entendre vos diatribles pour
cette présentation les gens suis très
fier et très honoré donc
pour cette année 2023 ou les deux et
Paul Prébois aussi de à mes heures
perdues je prends je prends pour 2023 on
continue notre tour de table à gauche
musique il est de retour dans cette
émission c'est l'un des meilleurs
journalistes sur le sport italien et sur
le sport Illinois le monde entier tente
de nous le piquer mais on arrive à le
conserver notre italienne lover est avec
nous pendant une heure
Pierrot bonjour à tous belle et heureuse
année sportive on est le 18 janvier là
encore temps de donner ses vœux on
espère avec beaucoup de succès pour nos
sportifs yvelinois et rassurez-vous vous
restez avec nous hein
je sais que le chantier vous pouvez vous
recrutez mais vous savez que de révéler
pas tout sur ce plateau mais non non
reste fidèle à la team bien sûr de sirop
par les sports on passe de l'autre côté
musique c'est un petit nouveau il vient
tout juste de fêter ses 60 ans on dit
qu'il gagne en expérience il est
responsable sponsoring chez Orange en
Île-de-France il adore le sport et
notamment le rugby et le football mais
il s'y connaît dans tous les sports
Philippe volak nous fait l'honneur de
venir dans cette émission un très grand
plaisir bonsoir Philippe un très grand
plaisir d'être parmi vous et d'assister
cette première émission pour moi et
c'est un c'est un bonheur on va parler
de sport ce que j'adore tous les sports
mais surtout le football et le rugby et
qu'est-ce que vous faites chez Orange je
suis responsable de sponsoring chez la
direction orangite de France
c'est-à-dire sur toute l'Île-de-France
et je suis aussi j'ai deux autres
casquettes je m'occupe des relations
publiques et de la presse aussi sur
l'île de France donc
un gros boulot et mais bon le sport
c'est mon c'est ma vocation et c'est et
j'adore ça et vous travaillez notamment
sur les enfants qui jouent à la mi-temps
des matchs de Ligue 1 par exemple
au Parc des Princes la mi-temps du PSG
avec des équipes aussi du 70 clubs du 78
voilà donc voilà j'aime voir briller les
yeux des enfants quand et voilà c'est ça
on termine de l'autre côté musique c'est
notre dessert notre galette des rois
c'est une légende dans cette émission
c'est coup de gueule pour trembler notre
studio mais rassurez-vous il peut être
très gentil coach Jean Miss excentrineur
de plaisir est avec nous quoi bonjour à
tous
comment allez-vous notre galette des
rois galette des rois moi je suis plus
entre baigner les Casimir mais sinon
avant de passer au programme de
l'émission on va parler de boxe dis-moi
après son échec face à Martin à bas
coller livinois Tony Yoka va remonter
sur le ring il va affronter le vétéran à
Franco camerounais carlosakam 42 ans le
combat est prévu le 11 mars prochain à
Paris un sacré morceau pour le boxeur
originaire de Chanteloup-les-Vignes car
le stackham a un bilan de 39 victoires
annule et 7 défaites tout simplement
messieurs est-ce que c'est la dernière
chance pour Tony Yoka
oui oui vous êtes unanime alors pourquoi
Jean
pourquoi tout simplement parce que là
s'il passe pas ce combat là mais c'est
fini pour lui il aura plus de il aura
plus de chance et malheureusement pour
lui il s'est planté la dernière fois et
j'espère pour lui qu'il a qu'il a
récupéré de ce combat qui s'est on sait
qu'il est qui s'est remis en préparation
et qu'il est au top maintenant il va
falloir qu'il soit plus qu'au top pour
franchir ce combat et cet adversaire qui
est au vu du palmarès que vous avez que
vous avez donné
une belle montagne a surmonter donc là
s'il passe pas là je crois que il peut
raccrocher les gars Philippe qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez moi je me dis que
encore à Paris il a pas le droit de se
il a pas le droit de se louper mais il a
pas le droit de se louper en plus devant
c'est supporters et je crois que c'est
ça dernière chance malheureusement bon
je pense que j'espère qu'il va être prêt
parce que le dernier combat ça a été dur
il a été vite au tapis et
dis-moi déjà
été dur je veux dire donc je pense que
c'est ça moi je pense que c'est sa
dernière chance dernière chance aussi
pour vous dire chevalier pour Tony Yoka
on en a très souvent parlé sur splato au
départ il avait le temps quand il est
passé de champion olympique à pro il
avait le temps il avait on va dire la
planète box devant lui et on lui
promettait déjà un avenir un avenir
radieux il y avait ses premiers combats
il était au rendez-vous et puis quand on
est quand on est allé au fond des choses
et justement sur ces premiers combats
professionnels ça a commencé à se
fissurer un petit peu et peut-être
peut-être aussi côté mental côté aussi
peut-être technique et lorsqu'on en a
parlé lors du combat l'année dernière
déjà l'année dernière ça remonte ça
remonte à loin contre bacoller oui il
avait il avait le décacé oui il a tenu
jusqu'au bout du combat et il a été au
justement de ce combat là il l'a perdu
et là il a plus le temps c'est le timing
ne joue plus pour lui et on l'avait dit
aussi c'est c'est il a besoin d'un test
un vrai test et là Carlos stackham c'est
ses hôtesses c'est pas le plus facile ça
c'est une évidence malgré l'âge il y a
l'expérience 42 ans voilà il y a
l'expérience et justement on box en box
ça peut sur un combat ça peut ça peut
compter et
yoga qui est plus jeune je pense qu'il
le sait il a il a ce rendez-vous là pour
poursuivre en gros chez les grands et
passer une étape parce que parce qu'en
gros sur le sur le circuit mondial il
doit passer ce petit ce type d'épreuve
là il a plus le choix dans la date il
faut qu'il avance il faut qu'il boxe il
faut qu'il gagne
il a il aura pas le choix il nous
rappelle le choix il a le vrai
interrogation j'en parlais c'est de
savoir comment il va aborder ce combat
et ce qui c'est totalement remis de sa
défaite il y a 10 mois face à Martin
bacoller lui-même le dit dans ses
interviews d'ailleurs on parle plus de
conquête c'était le mot qu'il avançait
il a changé un petit peu de slogan la
conquête pour aller vers ce titre
mondial lui-même l'a dit en interview
qu'il avait pensé carrément arrêter sa
carrière de boxeur il a 30 ans le temps
le temps presse pour lui qui rêve d'une
ceinture mondiale et c'est vrai que
finalement ce combat tombe un peu à pied
pour lui on va voir si c'est remis
totalement de de cette défaite il y a 10
mois car le stackham c'est un excellent
adversaire pierre l'a rappelé alors qui
est plutôt en fin de carrière qui aura à
cœur de battre Yoka on présente ce match
un peu déjà comme le jubilé de Carlos
stackham donc forcément il va être
remonté à bloc pour pour l'affronter et
donc oui c'est le tournant aujourd'hui
si le bas car le stockage il se remet
dans une confiance parce que Carlos
Takam c'est pas n'importe quel
adversaire c'est un adversaire peut-être
l'un des meilleurs boxeurs français sur
ces 15 dernières années qui a affronté
des grands boxeurs comme Joshua où il a
à chaque fois aussi bien figuré contre
contre ces boxeurs donc c'est le
tournant si le bas il se remet en
confiance maintenant si il y a cette
défaite aujourd'hui on verrait quand
même très très mal le voir rebondir
après ce serait difficile pour lui il
pourra arrêter peut-être sa carrière
s'il y a une défaite à votre avis Jean
je crois que là la déception elle était
déjà suite après après bacoller là je
crois que là je pense pas qu'il s'enlève
à mon avis c'est maintenant ou jamais
ouais moi je crois que là c'est sa
dernière chose et il le sait il est pas
bête il s'est pertinemment que les gens
le temps joue contre lui et que là c'est
terminé tous les spécialistes golf le
disait dans ceux qui parlaient de ce
combat poste post-bacoller c'est surtout
le c'est surtout le gros le fait de
digérer cette défaite il y a dû être
difficile sur la partie sur le scénario
le scénario de la défaite et du combat
même s'il a été au bout c'est tout le
l'enjeu c'est de savoir si c'est
vraiment remis dans la tronche de ce de
cette défaite et si il est capable de
repartir de plus belle contre takan
il joue pas golf j'ai dit golf moi
peut-être
c'est la place
alors nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
allons parler de la défaite de notre
tennisman Arthur rinderknech à l'Open
d'Australie nous parlerons aussi du
Parisis qui partira pour la 14e fois des
Yvelines mais avant de parler de ces
thématiques on va parler football et du
FC Versailles
[Musique]
certains comparent le FC Versailles à
Dallas nous on n'ira pas jusque là mais
presque il faut dire que ce club nous
fait beaucoup parler depuis le début de
la saison sur ce plateau dernière grosse
information en date le départ du
directeur général Jean-Luc Arribart un
départ pressenti depuis de nombreuses
semaines le consultant de Canal+ était
arrivé au FC Versailles en 2021 avec
l'ambition de voir le club monté en
National une ce départ s'ajoute à celui
de Youssef chibil entraîneur historique
du club il a été mis à pied en novembre
dernier il a été remplacé par l'ancien
joueur de Lyon Chris il y a aussi de
nombreux départs au sein des joueurs et
beaucoup d'arriver ces changements
sont-ils positifs pour le club oui ou
non vous votez
ces changements sont-ils positifs pour
le club partagez pour vous Grégory
partagez pour vous gens non pour vous
Philippe et partagez aussi pour vous
Pierre Philippe alors vous êtes le plus
catégorique sur la question pourquoi
je pense pas que ça va
ce sera pas ce sera pas comment ce sera
pas ouais comme je dis ce sera pas ce
sera pas positif tout ce qui se passe
l'intérieur d'un club bien sûr il y a le
sportif on dit qu'on mélange pas le
sportif et ce qui se passe à côté mais
là c'est quand même un club nouveau
quand quelque part qui monte qui est en
National qui a fait un bon bon départ je
dirais ils ont été deuxième ils ont été
premier ils sont je crois qu'ils doivent
être donc voilà donc il faut que ça
reparte donc c'est sûr que c'était la
trêve faut que ça faut que ça faut que
ça reparte mais
moi je pense que
je sais pas je vais pouvoir ce qu'il y a
des il y a des équipes comme le Red Star
il y a qui remonte bien il y a il y a
que deux clubs je crois à monter je
crois donc en plus cette année cette
saison c'est difficile à tous les à tous
les échelons pour les pour les monter
les descentes
mais pour moi je pense pas que ça va je
pense pas que ça va je pense pas que ça
va jouer je pense que je pense que ils
vont continuer c'est pas sur les joueurs
parce qu'ils ont quand même les joueurs
ils ont quand même mis encore je crois
recruté encore quelqu'un encore il y a
un bon joueur il y a pas un jeune
rigolais voilà et donc je pense que ils
ont le au niveau sportif ils ont ils ont
l'effectif bon maintenant faut tenir
c'est sûr sur la sur la sur la saison
hein faut tenir aussi sur la saison mais
je suis je suis positif je suis quand
même Pierre Chevalier la skimber ce qui
me perturbe un petit peu c'est le c'est
le c'est l'enchaînement des choses et
l'impression que le management il est un
peu décousu c'est à dire que les départs
et les arrivées se font se un petit peu
dans le désordre si on considère le tout
début de la saison en National depuis la
montée la présence de de Jean-Luc
Arribart a été déjà un peu remise en
question déjà avec tous ces films on
savait on savait que le que les deux ne
s'entendaient pas que même Jean-Luc
avait en plus le l'interdiction de
rentrer dans le rentrer dans le
vestiaire des versaillers quelques mois
plus tard quelques semaines quelques
mois plus tard c'est donc c'est les
affaires ou l'affaire qui rattrape
Youssef chibi et il est il est mis à
pied l'arrivée de crise derrière et puis
finalement à se demander qui qui décide
et qui qui dirige au FC Versailles là
avec le départ de Jean-Luc Arribart
c'est sans doute la confirmation que ce
sont les présidents les deux
co-présidents qui qui mène au destinées
du FC Versailles là où j'étais
qu'on n'entend pas du tout mais qui a
priori font plus que vrai
en gestion en gestion j'allais dire en
coulisse mais c'est un peu ça ils sont
ils sont présidents et finalement ils
gèrent quand même le club sur les
départs et les arrivées quel que soit le
niveau au niveau des joueurs au niveau
de l'encadrement là où j'ai des mitigé
c'est que c'est que il y a une chose qui
caractérise Versailles le FC Versailles
c'est la force du groupe notamment
sportif et là sur l'expérience de l'an
dernier sur les arrivées de joueurs
d'expérience malgré tout et sur les et
sur le la qualité globale du groupe il
se retrouve après une première saison
mi-saison en tête du championnat avec
des prestations qui sont quand même des
prestations largement largement aboutie
sur sur des matchs de football donc un
peu mitigé par par ça parce qu'en fait
avec ça parce que on a maintenant on a
un entraîneur un nom d'entraîneur de
joueurs plutôt et futur peut-être non
d'entraîneur avec Chris qui a qui a fait
ses armements et qui maintenant commence
à bien prendre en main sport au moins
sportivement le groupe il y a eu un
petit accident contre Saint-Brieuc et
puis basta maintenant ils ont ils ont
repris la marche en avant et on est
toujours on est toujours on est toujours
dans un rythme de montée
de double montée là cette année donc un
peu mitigé en disant que il y a beaucoup
de il y a beaucoup de faits de de clubs
qui défrayent un peu la chronique mais
malgré tout sportivement sur le terrain
ça fait ça fait encore le job donc même
si c'est Dallas pour vous aussi à
Grégory
c'est pas c'est pas très grave non c'est
pas très alors sur le court terme c'est
pas très grave quand on prend
effectivement le bilan de crise depuis
qu'il est arrivé alors Saint-Brice c'est
juste avant qu'il soit nommé mais
effectivement après le départ du selfie
il y a eu cette défaite contre
Saint-Brieuc
a pris 13 points sur 12 points sur 15
possibles donc il a quasiment rempli on
va dire les objectifs aujourd'hui les
premiers execo du championnat national
donc sur le plan sportif ça marche bien
et même les recrues il y avait m&ens
dont on sait pas moqué en plateau mais
on disait qu'il était revenu avec
beaucoup de kilos en trop bah finalement
comment ça à se fondre dans l'effectif
et là il a marqué il a marqué deux buts
récemment mais le dernier face à
Avranches dans dans la victoire de
Versailles trois business donc sur le
court terme pour l'instant ils sont ils
sont dans le vrai maintenant reste à
savoir si sur le long terme est-ce que
ça va avoir impacter durablement
l'équipe le club qui est tous ces
changements c'est assez surprenant le
départ de Jean-Luc Arribart moins sur on
va dire le calendrier alors on sait que
jean-lucaribar était mis de côté depuis
le début de la saison parce que les
pleins pouvoirs sportifs avaient été
donné à Youssef chibi mais depuis le
départ du chef chibi on aurait pu
peut-être espérer un retour un peu plus
central de jean-lucaribas j'avoue que
moi ça m'a surpris d'avoir cette cette
information fin décembre maintenant
est-ce que tous ces changements à
vouloir aller trop vite à vouloir viser
très vite le soleil aller très vite en
Ligue 2 est-ce que ça va pas on va pas
se brûler les ailes au bout d'un moment
pour pour ce club du soleil ce club de
la cité royale voilà j'espère pas donc
avoir sur le court terme ça marche je
suis plus mitigé sur le long terme avoir
les conséquences qui pourraient y avoir
avec tous ces changements au sein du
club vous comprenez genre pourquoi on
essaie de nous le piquer un Grégory
fantastique
et entier essaie de nous piquer
ce que vous en pensez vous alors moi
j'étais mitigé tout simplement parce que
sportivement mais on l'a tous dit ça
ça marche bien ça gaz ils sont premiers
execo maintenant pour l'instant on ne
peut rien dire maintenant un club qui
qui cherche à se structurer pour aller
chercher le niveau Ligue 2
professionnels et puis après aller
commencer à se frotter au grand c'est
pas la meilleure manière de s'y prendre
c'est pour ça que j'étais un petit peu
mitigé parce que bon on se sépare du
directeur général
bon le changement d'entraîneur ça c'est
pas eux qui l'ont voulu c'est elle
aurait été imposer par par l'actualité
ça c'est mais force de reconnaître que
Chris il arrive très bien puisque il
avait une si bien dit il a pris 12
points sur 15 possible 13 sur 15 13 sur
15 minutes donc voilà donc résultat plus
que favorable sportivement mais encore
une fois c'est c'est ce petit bémol
c'est que pour se structurer pour aller
franchir cette haute marche de la Ligue
2 c'est pas le meilleur moyen il fallait
mieux qu'ils aient de la stabilité au
sein du groupe au du club pas du groupe
parce que le groupe sportivement il va
bien mais au sein du club une stabilité
serait nécessaire pour justement
préparer cette éventuelle montée en
Ligue 2 et qui va remplacer du coup
jean-lucariba vous avez des infos
peut-être pire chevalier pas du tout
est-ce qu'il va être remplacer je pense
que tout on avait eu cette rumeurs en
fin d'année que que le torchon brûlé
déjà sur la partie direction générale
mais pas plus de pas plus d'informations
au coin du au coin du vestiaire et du
terrain à portfontaine ni à montboron
sur ni à jambon
le carnet d'adresses dont pouvait faire
profiter Jean-Luc Arribart au club du FC
Versailles donc on va voir la suite il y
a un peu une nomination qui s'est faite
un peu dans dans l'anonymat celle d'Enzo
débally qui a été lui nommé conseil en
recrutement et mutation donc ça change
ça bouge un tout petit peu dans
l'organigramme du club même si on a
regardé tout à l'heure sur le site
Internet il est pas encore tout à fait à
jour l'organigramme du club donc c'est
vrai il faut se structurer
elle se fait majoritairement par
communiquer de presse en fait c'est des
communiqués qui tombent et c'est c'est
c'est une c'est une communication
finalement assez institutionnelle et qui
est assez régulière parce qu'il se passe
plein de choses
en tout cas notre si on parlait sport je
suis euh plusieurs semaines c'était
plusieurs semaines quand même plusieurs
mois enfin au tout début alors qu'on
savait que au niveau de l'affaire voilà
il est quand même resté
une affaire résumé innocent pour
l'instant d'innocence il aurait espionné
des personnes à leur insu des tensions
aussi d'images pédopornographiques
Philippe est-ce que c'est peut-être pas
le moment aussi peut-être de tout
chambouler finalement pour pour grandir
encore plus
je sais pas je non je pense pas que ce
soit le il y a pas de moments en fin de
compte il y a pas de moments pour
chambouler
très serré en a vu que classement
on se retrouve ça va ça va très vite et
ainsi si ça peut les aider avant la fin
de de recrutement fin janvier si ça peut
les aider à repartir là de toute façon
il faudra bien c'est même pas repartir
c'est repartir au niveau comme on disait
tout à l'heure encadrement parce que au
niveau sportif c'est bon comme je le
disais mais il faut que ça se stabilise
de toute façon faut pas que ça tarde de
trop à se stabiliser parce que c'est
cette année s'ils veulent monter aussi
c'est cette année parce que après c'est
Simon de cette année c'est c'est top
parce qu'il y a quatre équipes comme de
Ligue 2 qui descendent il y a que deux
qui montent il y a il y a une
restructuration des groupes donc je
pense que faut vraiment faut vraiment si
on peut monter cette année il faut qu'il
monte cette année mais on a vu en tout
cas qu'il y a une volonté de changement
de dimension et ne serait-ce que sur les
préparations ils sont partis 6 jours en
stage Casablanca au Maroc pour une
équipe de nationale c'est vrai que de
partir sur des destinations on va dire
pas exotique mais des destinations pour
préparer dans des pays un peu plus
chauds l'hiver pour préparer la saison
ça soyez pas forcément national donc on
va très vite ils ont envie de devenir
professionnel et ce qu'il faut dire
voilà c'est que pour le moment en tout
cas le groupe vit plutôt bien ça permet
de resserrer les liens aussi ce stage ça
a été dit dans les différentes
interviews qui ont été donnés sur place
pour répondre à vos questions c'est
peut-être maintenant qu'on peut dire que
le maintien est assuré pour un montant
que peut-être que c'est ils ont encore
un joker à griller pour éventuellement
tout chamboulé mais je pense qu'ils ont
basculé dans une autre dimension
l'appétit vient en mangeant et en
l'occurrence là ils sont ils sont
premiers de premier de national avec
justement cette montée qui leur tend les
bras dès la première année donc c'est le
timing a du la du changer
ils sont favoris maintenant pour la
montée à votre avis Jean en plus
enflammer quoi
donc comme on l'a dit Philippe ça va
très vite une effet tenue et
le reste
non parce qu'en plus ce sont des promus
donc bon faut pas non plus s'enflammer
mais quand même ils y sont ils y restent
pour l'instant donc prenons laissons le
temps au temps d'énergie avec la Coupe
de France puisqu'ils sont déjà
en France malheureusement on a plus de
club vivinois engagé dans cette Coupe de
France alors dans notre prochaine
thématique on va parler tennis avec une
très mauvaise nouvelle pour notre
yvelinoir tuerie le Saint-Germain noir
c'est incliné sèchement face aux
qualifié japonais Yusuki Yatta Nuki en
1h43 le score 6-3-6-3-6-2 pourtant 79
place mondiales séparés les deux hommes
Arthur Riner a été le défoncer à prendre
la porte du côté de Melbourne il a dit
qu'il voulait à débriefer sa défaite
avec son staff après une préparation
tronquée il est désormais numéro 4
français la question sur cette
thématique est-ce que c'est un flop pour
lui cet Open d'Australie oui
oui après mitigé sur le reste mais
j'expliquerai
c'est un flop
forcément dès le premier tour dès le
premier tour dehors
dans sachant qu'il ne brille pas
forcément en bon Chelem
voilà sois formel bon il avait bien
figuré l'année dernière et là dès le
premier tour il sort face à un inconnu
parce que je serais même pas répéter le
nom Yusuke yatanuki
voilà mais non mais forcément forcément
pour un sportif
ok à qui on attend on attend beaucoup
euh là là c'est une désillusion totale
voilà 79 places qui les sépare au
premier tour
alors que lui ben il brille quand même
autre chose que que ce genre de
résultats il peut débriefer avec avec
son staff à mon avis il y a de quoi il y
a de quoi parler mais bon non non pour
moi c'est c'est négatif à tout point de
vue j'espère qu'il ne doit pas nous
sortir une blessure il était pas blessé
non
c'est la préparation n'a pas été
optimale pour peindre ce le niveau d'un
Grand Chelem oui
il bascule un petit peu la
responsabilité sur son encadrement quoi
quelque part
si je crois 6 2
effectivement il y a plus qu'à
l'opération
Philippe qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
vous le connaissez Arthur et note je le
connais je l'ai suivi parce que c'est
vrai qu'il a commencé c'est un âge quand
même on n'est pas habitué à voir quand
il a commencé il a comme un âge certain
je veux dire il avait 23 23 24 ans
professionnel non je pense qu'il a
perdre contre bon on va pas dire un
inconnu c'est quand même c'est quand
même et puis on a on s'attendait quand
même un meilleur résultat au moins même
le deuxième tour je crois que c'était
encore c'était facile c'était ça
semblait facile aussi et puis ben voilà
ok on parle de lui mais on parle aussi
de tous les autres de tous les autres
Français
à date là il en reste plus qu'un c'est
un berge qui a battu qui a battu
aujourd'hui
comment Gasquet et le colis qui s'est
fait battre aussi en 5,7 aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que c'est comme Mouté aussi
c'est quand même je dirais moi je
pensais quand même que qu'il allait au
moins passer un ou deux tours et voilà
il faut pas qu'il replonge parce que
c'est pas un jour de challenger de toute
façon donc il faut quand même qu'il
passe des tours réalité numéro français
il y a encore quelques semaines et là il
a quand même un Français autour d'après
c'est quand ils s'affrontent
pour rebondir c'est c'est j'ai du mal à
j'ai du mal à m'y retrouver dans le
tennis masculin français là ou alors au
minimum c'est qu'il est plante surprise
ce tennis masculin français parce que là
on a eu en l'espace de 4 semaines un
bouleversement quasiment total de la
hiérarchie en tête du classement des
meilleurs joueurs français je parle pas
du classement mondial mais des meilleurs
joueurs français où on a Richard Gasquet
qui revient de nulle part qui fait une
relance du parking et qui gagne et qui
gagne en Nouvelle-Zélande et qui est qui
après ce Ben se remet dans la dans la
dans la peau du premier français du
français du numéro en français et puis
on a on a Arthur qui voilà pour
l'instant
mais voilà bah tu pars un maire
aujourd'hui dans les duels
franco-français qui nous donnent au
moins un français sur le Tour d'après et
Arthur qui qu'on suit qu'on suit depuis
le début ici et qui effectivement nous
donne une déception parce que parce que
généralement mais bon lui lui réussit
plutôt bien et que et que sur le papier
sur un match comme celui-là il y avait
pas il y avait pas de danger de danger
majeur peut-être en trois sept ans
vraiment sec il y a rien à dire c'est
une jolie fessée et puis et puis on
reviendra l'année prochaine après
maintenant c'est c'est peut-être sa
préparation ok bien réfléchir là-dessus
si surtout en gros sur le sur le mental
et sur la préparation de la suite de sa
saison Grégory ben oui tu as des
éléments nous apporter
l'essentialité dit c'est vrai que sur
cette Open d'Australie c'est une grosse
déception tout le monde l'a rappelé il
faisait face à un qualifié lui il est
58e mondial il avait quand même un
statut à faire respecter il n'a pas
réussi à le faire respecter en plus il
perd en 3 7 déception aussi parce que
son passé récent à l'Open d'Australie
était plutôt bon l'année dernière il
franchit le premier on se souvient avec
un stade qui était pas forcément à son
avantage qui était même plutôt contre
lui puisque il élimine un Australien au
premier tour le deuxième tour manque de
chance manque de chance parce que il est
blessé et il est obligé de renoncer donc
on attendait on était vraiment sur notre
fin on attendait de voir Arthur
hinderkness peut-être briller dans un
tournoi du Grand Chelem parce que c'est
vrai que s'il a des titres sur le
circuit de challenger on attend quand
même que sur le circuit ATP voilà qui
puisse remporter des titres de ce
prestige maintenant c'est vrai que j'ai
été mitigé parce que si il est vrai que
c'est un flop sur cet Open d'Australie
moi j'ai envie de dire dans la carrière
d'Arthur underknech finit par appeler
son parcours atypique ou des rentré
assez tard sur le circuit j'ai envie de
dire tout ce qui lui arrive de bien et
bon à prendre et c'est que c'est que du
bonus ce qui lui arrive aujourd'hui on
espérait pas il y a encore deux trois
ans donc c'est pour ça que je reste
quand même mitigé de le voir quand même
58e mondial avec son passé avec son
profil de jour atypique ça reste quand
même une réussite maintenant sur cet
événement monstre descendre jusqu'à la
70e place mondiale à peu près 75e ça va
très vite et c'est vrai que on est déçu
il a terminé l'année comme numéro un
français même si c'est dans un contexte
où le tennis français masculin va très
mal voilà heureusement que de l'autre
côté chez les femmes il y a qui regarde
Garcia mais oui déçu sur sur cet
événement moins sur l'ensemble de sa
carrière quand même on va maintenant
parler cyclisme c'est officiel la ville
de La Verrière 6000 habitants a été
choisi pour lancer la 88e édition de la
course cycliste Paris-Nice le dimanche 5
mars prochain les coureurs partiront de
la commune yvelinoise pour 169,4 km
direction la vallée de Chevreuse avant
de revenir vers le Mesnil-Saint-Denis en
passant par la côte des 17 tournants
pour la verrière ce sera une grande
première on écoute le maire de la
commune cet historique en un mot une
vraie fierté une vraie fierté pour la
ville d'accueillir un événement
planétaire avec près de 8 millions de
téléspectateurs qu'on les yeux rivés sur
la verrière et puis sur le
Mesnil-Saint-Denis puisque l'étape par
de la verrière et arrive au Mesnil c'est
un engouement populaire c'est une étape
sans précédent dont on est vraiment très
très fier
le lendemain le lundi 6 mars c'est la
petite commune de bazinville 1500
habitants qui va accueillir l'épreuve le
départ de la deuxième étape sera donnée
place Saint-Nicolas là aussi ce sera une
grande première pour la commune on
écoute le maire très grande fierté on
remercie le département d'avoir pensé à
notre beau village et on attend avec
impatience ce 6 mars pour pouvoir
accueillir cette deuxième étape de
Paris-Nice est-ce que vous êtes content
messieurs pour ces deux communes la
verrière et Bazainville très content
Philippe qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
oui très content
relativement petite commune
c'est pas le Tour de France mais c'est
quand même la première le première
grosse course de l'année quand même donc
en espérant que que notre champion soit
là soit là au départ je sais pas si il
sera là au départ mais c'est bien pour
ces petites villes ça les met ça les met
en valeur on montre voilà que même 1500
habitants on peut on peut faire quelque
chose on peut faire un départ
et c'est bien aussi pour les pour les
habitants et pour parce que en fin de
compte après si on compare le Tour de
France autour de France et ça part
souvent des gros des grosses villes des
grosses villes et bon c'est pas non plus
le même le même Oran non plus hein Tour
de France n'est pas non plus mes Paris
Nice c'est déjà comme je disais c'est la
première course de la saison grosse
course de la saison donc je pense que
c'est c'est bien pour c'est c'est bien
pour ces petites villes puis je sais que
de toute façon ils veulent toujours
partir de des Yvelines donc c'est un
mythe c'est un voilà donc voilà
on va pas on va pas changer et pourquoi
cette ville là pas une autre donc ils
sont tous voilà on voyait les petits et
merveilles ils sont ils sont satisfaits
c'est quand ils vont être sous les il y
aura d'ailleurs le Tour de France à
ville de garde qui sera présent au
départ de ce Paris-Nice et en plus donc
c'est quand même dans ces c'est c'est
très bien ça fait du coup 14 ans
consécutifs que le Paris-Nice passe par
les Yvelines et plupart des Yvelines
même et cela ne sont pas près de
s'arrêter on écoute le président du
Département Pierre-Bénite trois ans
quatre ans mais bon en fait ça n'a pas
de limite retenons surtout ce message
parce que les Yvelines c'est une terre
de vélo nous sommes durablement associés
avec ces grands événements sportifs que
sont et le Tour de France et le pénis la
question sur cette thématique le
parinise doit-il rester dans les
Yvelines pour toujours comme le veut
Pierre Bédier oui pour vous Jean oui
pour pour tout le monde autour de cette
table alors pourquoi Jean parce qu'il
l'a dit mais non il l'a dit tout à
l'heure
de vélo les Yvelines est une terre de
vue mais c'est vrai il y a le Paris-Nice
c'est quand même la première course
certes mais une course très très connue
très très connue parinise tout le monde
connaît c'est voilà c'est une course
emblématique
emblématique et on voit l'engouement que
ça crée à travers les interviews des
mères des deux des deux petites villes
concernées mais c'est fabuleux il faut
continuer comme ça parce que déjà c'est
bien rodé ça fonctionne bien tout le
monde adhère parce que encore une fois
les Yvelines terre de vélo donc pourquoi
pourquoi ça s'arrêterait pourquoi
essayer de le mettre ailleurs pourquoi
quand tu as quelque chose fonctionne on
essaie de de changer non ça fonctionne
pour une fois en France soyons bon
français quand ça fonctionne garde-le il
y aura le voilà comment je dire à
Saint-Quentin donc de Saint-Quentin donc
voilà faut pas faut pas penser tout de
suite arrêtez non surtout
pour vous aussi trois raisons la
première c'est c'est une question de une
question de culture je vais pas revenir
sur ce que dit ce que vient de dire Jean
la culture du vélo dans les Yvelines moi
amateur grand amateur devant l'éternel
du de cyclisme je les vois je les vois
tous les dimanches tous les samedis tout
le temps tout le temps sur les routes
des Yvelines et donc c'est une terre de
vélo
je plaisante
pas tant que ça et donc la culture et la
culture pour les Yvelines pour les
Yvelines et pour les quasiment
l'histoire ou l'histoire l'histoire de
la petite reine dans les Yvelines
deuxièmement pour une question de
logistique il y a il y a un pari tout
proche déjà l'arrivée du Tour de France
sur la plus grande la plus grande course
cycliste qui soit et donc c'est c'est
organisé comme tel depuis 14 ans et ça a
montré ça a montré en gros c'est c'est
ses avantages et ses vertus de pouvoir
en gros mettre les Yvelines les Yvelines
en avant et sans savoir faire exactement
et troisièmement justement c'est sur la
c'est sur l'aspect sur l'aspect
événementiel organisationnel sur
l'expérience des Yvelines dans
cette dans cette mise en place
d'événements que sont les départs du
Paris-Nice qui est une qui est une
course qui est qui est qui on va dire
peut-être pas aussi mythique que les
classiques mais qui est la première et
une vieille course et une des plus
grandes courses reconnues au monde parce
que parce qu'en France comme dans les
Yvelines on fait du vélo Grégory oui
mais les Yvelines terre de vélo il y a
qu'à prendre les prochains jeux
olympiques alors pour toujours
prenons juste les prochains jeux
olympiques la course cycliste sur route
passera dans les Yvelines le cyclisme
surpiste sera au vélo de Rome le BMX
sera au vélo de Rome le VTT à Élancourt
il y a ce départ du Paris-Nice voilà on
continue les Yvelines terre de vélo il
faut assumer cette
identité et moi je pense aussi ouais
c'est une superbe exposition aussi pour
ces deux communes chaque année on change
de commune ça permet aussi de réviser un
peu notre géographie des Yvelines et de
la faire connaître au monde entier mais
la dernière c'est c'est super pour la
dernière pour ses habitants qui est une
ville qui est en changement en ce moment
en cours de en cours de mutation avec de
nombreux travaux qui qui sont prévus sur
place ça permet de parler de cette ville
de sur d'autres actualités des
actualités beaucoup plus positives et
bases voilà c'est le côté rural on est
toujours à cheval sur ce département des
ions entre le
urbain et le rural ça permet de montrer
cette cette double identité donc oui il
faut continuer pourquoi arrêter alors
que ça marche ça marche très bien ce
serait dommage donc
que le Tour de France quand ça part des
Yvelines ils partent à 10 km/h je veux
dire il parcourt le il parcours les
Yvelines à 10 km/h tandis que la Paris
c'est la première étape ils vont la
course c'est parti très très belle dans
les Yvelines notamment Bois-d'Arcy je
crois que c'était en 2017 si je me
trompe pas ou l'arrivée s'était faite
dernière sur la dernière ligne droite
sous la neige
le Tour de France bah cette année aussi
va repartir des Yvelines il y a eu une
petite année l'année dernière dans les
Hauts-de-Seine même un passage mais
cette année en tout cas ça partira du
vélo de route de 50 ans en Yvelines
c'est justement la beauté des paysages
yvelinois pour pour justement en
mondiaux vision pour montrer
78 raisons
de passer à notre page débat
[Musique]
on va passer à l'envolée de Grégory le
moment le plus attendu de cette émission
le moment le plus mythique de quoi les
vous nous parlez Grégory d'un sport
connu mondialement et grâce notamment un
événement dans la nuit du 12 au 13
février prochain des millions de
personnes auront les yeux braqués sur le
Super Bowl la 57e édition de la finale
de la Ligue de football américain se
déroulera au state Pharm Stadium de
glendal en Arizona un rendez-vous suivi
l'année dernière par 112 millions de
téléspectateurs et en plus du spectacle
sur le terrain on sait que le show à la
mi-temps est particulièrement attendu
avec à chaque fois un concert d'artistes
de renom cette année c'est Rihanna
est-ce que vous êtes content du retour
de Rihanna Michael je suis extrêmement
content du retour de Rihanna je
l'attendais depuis de nombreuses années
j'ai même soumis l'idée aux
organisateurs et ils ont accepté je suis
content ce qui vous a marqué vous à la
mi-temps du Super Bowl un concert vous
retenez il y en a eu de nombreux
artistes Shakira
nos yeux disent Linois vont suivre dans
quelques jours le retour sur les
terrains des Templiers les joueurs
d'Élancourt font leur début de saison de
Division 2 casque d'or elle mie d'or en
italien d'ailleurs ça veut dire casque
d'or
avec cette division j'adore le football
américain ils sont remontés en courtois
eux qui se préparent physiquement depuis
septembre ils joueront leur première
journée de championnat à l'extérieur
contre les Léopards de Rouen écoutez ils
sont très motivés c'est le match qui me
motive c'est les matchs qui me qui me
pousse et
pas pourra revenir sur notre confiance
c'est surtout une année où on arrive en
début de championnat sans trop de
blessures on arrive vraiment avec
comment dire un bilan médical qui est
plutôt bon on a très peu de joueurs
blessés des joueurs qui ont joué toute
la saison dernière blessé qui se sont
bien reposés et qui se sont bien
soignées et là on revient en pleine
forme elle l'effectif c'est assez
largement renouvelé beaucoup de joueurs
issus de la formation et en courtoises
qui est très reconnu ont été recruté par
des équipes de plus grands standing des
jeunes du club des Templiers vont donc
intégrer ou intégrer déjà l'équipe
première quelques renforts de
l'extérieur aussi et peut-être un apport
US ils ont pas été très clair encore sur
le sujet ils ont pas voulu tout révéler
parce que ça peut capoter au dernier
moment parce qu'il se piquent les les
import US en fait en Europe et du coup
tant que ce n'est pas signé ce n'est pas
signé donc ils ont pas voulu nous dire
qui va renforcer ses pompiers un ou deux
on verra pour la pour cette saison car
pour les Templiers en D2 depuis 2017
après plusieurs années dans l’élite
l'objectif est de se qualifier au moins
pour les playoffs avant de rêver de la
Division 1 là on est sur une phase de
reconstruction on est sur une phase de
recrutrition en fait qui prend son temps
et elle est pérenne elle est pérenne
puisqu'on arrive à rester justement dans
cette deuxième division on accède
régulièrement aux phase de playoffs et
je pense que cet objectif doit être en
continu l'accession playoff et après
viser toujours plus haut l'année
dernière c'est ce qui nous est arrivé on
nous fait un bon parcours malgré 7 ou 8
blessés en un match qui nous a un peu
mal mis on finit par battre notre
concurrent direct qui est le repas de
Rouen qu'on recroise ce weekend et on
perd en playoff face aux champions 2e
division je pense que c'est un parcours
qu'on peut atteindre encore cette année
en tout cas on doit tendre à à aller
dans cette direction un sport très
exigeant beaucoup de blessés souvent
dans ce sport du football américain
alors un retour dans l'élite pour les
Templiers que moi personnellement
j'aimerais voir de tout mon cœur les
Templiers ont eu de très belles années
un passé glorieux à un titre de champion
de France de D2 c'était en mais aussi de
vis champion en D1 en 2008 il y a eu
aussi des épopées européennes finalistes
de les FAF Cup en 2005 c'est la deuxième
compétition la plus importante du Vieux
Continent 2500 personnes étaient venues
au stade Guy Boniface elle encore alors
c'est pas les images que l'on voit mais
il y avait eu notamment là on les voit
évoluer au Parc des Sports de l'Europe
complexe sportif de l'Europe elle est en
cours mais en 2005 cette finale
aberrations 2500 personnes au stade Guy
Boniface qui n'est pas très loin il y a
même eu un parcours jusqu'en demi-finale
de la prestigieuse européenne Football
League alors il y a eu du monde de
belles ambiances au complexe sportif de
l'Europe je disais qu'il accueille
habituellement les matchs des Templiers
revoir les les Templiers en D1
pourraient donner dans les Yvelines
allez peut-être un coup de pouce à la
popularité du foot US qui ben un peu de
l'aile en ce moment bien que très connu
dans le monde le football américain
reste un sport de niche en France la
discipline a même fortement souffert
alors du covid-19 une paire de 7
licenciés en France entre 2019 et 2022
donc on a toujours de besoin de belles
histoires pour faire rep sortir ce sport
quel football américain je voulais dire
allez les Templiers on est on est bien
sûr tous derrière vous pour une montée
en D1 cette saison à la fin de la saison
le foot US peut-il percer en France
après ce que vient de vous dire Grégory
dans sa magnifique envolée est-ce que ça
peut percer en France vous qui êtes en
plus rugbyman vous n'êtes pas très loin
au niveau du football américain pas très
loin vous êtes partagé tout le monde est
partagé
Philippe et après je donnerai la parole
à Pierre
moi je connais pas assez bien le le
football le football américain donc mais
en France oui en France en France donc
voilà enfin d'après ce que dit
l'entraîneur et le joueur bon ils sont
ils sont confiants
mais voilà il y a quand même voilà c'est
comme difficile il y a le il y a le
rugby donc c'est sûr il y a beaucoup de
beaucoup de clubs je sais pas comment il
y a de clubs au niveau au niveau France
mais on sait pas voilà c'est
moi je suis ouais je suis mitigé je suis
mitigé pierre en français en Europe on a
on a importé des États-Unis que quelques
petites choses qui ont fonctionné il y a
Halloween et les fast food on va dire en
gros
en tête d'une liste en tête d'une liste
qui peut être longue sur ce qu'on a
apporté on sport en sport c'est la
greffe ne prend pas ne prend pas souvent
le basket le basket et le basket a pris
et avec notamment les normes rouleaux
compresseur que représente à NBA et
répondez aussi à une à une pratique du
basket qui était peut-être plus
antérieure en France et en Europe quand
on prend après des sports typiques
américains type baseball football foot
US ok ouais avec les Canadiens et les
Canadiens les Canadiens et les
Américains là pour le coup on souffre je
pense d'un déficit de culture de culture
sportive et de pratiques parce que c'est
plus récent parce que on a pas eu
suffisamment d'apports de joueurs
peut-être en fin de carrière par exemple
qui viennent faire du prosélytisme et
qui viennent en gros qui viennent porter
la bonne parole du baseball ou du foutus
en France et que on a on a cette ce
manque de culture sportive au sens très
large de l'Inter timons parce que c'est
ça aussi qui marche au foot US c'est le
spectacle c'est le super Ball qui qui
fait un méga show autour du sport le
sport est presque devenu un prétexte
d'un méga chaud et en France ça je sais
que ça fonctionne pas on a on a un
limite dans des salles des concerts et
des artistes qui remplissent des salles
à l'intérieur ou des stades le Stade de
France qu'on ne sait pas quand c'est pas
du rugby ou du foot mais on n'a pas
encore passé le cap de ce sport
Entertainment qui qui fonctionne très
bien aux US et
avec en plus des temps des temps de
saison qui sont qui sont là aussi
décalés démarrer en janvier une saison
de sport c'est pas forcément le meilleur
moyen d'amener des spectateurs ne
serait-ce que des spectateurs donc c'est
là où je suis motivé je suis mitigé il y
a des pratiquants il y a des passionnés
pour l'instant ça rencontre pas encore
l'approbation globale des spectateurs on
a pu on a pu voir à l'écran que j'ai pu
tester le football américain voilà j'ai
pu tester est-ce que voilà
exactement
une action là qui va qui va arriver un
plaquage de Michael voilà
je ne comprends pas pourquoi ça ne
fonctionne pas vous avez pu voir il y a
du spectacle en football américain voilà
il protection une petite pensée pour
Rudi je crois qui est qui m'a plaqué ce
jour-là et et qui s'est fait mal oui
avec deux trois côtés en moi mais ça va
je m'en suis remis oui effectivement
genre du coup vous vous êtes pas sûr que
ça perce un jour le football je peux
revenir juste que Pierre a dit là il a
trouvé bien défini beaucoup de points à
chaque fois Pierre
après un ou deux joueurs américains bon
c'est bien mais ça me fait penser un peu
au en milieu de France quand un joueur
de rugby arrive du Sud-Ouest qu'il a
l'accent on croit toujours que c'est un
beau joueur et une fois sur deux c'est
une pompe mais bon
c'est pas parce que là c'est joli que
l'histoire est belle mais il est sympa
non mais non mais c'est pas ça je veux
dire c'est pas parce que il est
américain que le gars il est forcément
bon
mais bon ça c'était la parenthèse
ça c'était la parade thèse mais c'est
vrai que pour revenir
les coachs c'est le plus mauvais le plus
le plus mauvais rôle qu'on peut avoir
quand on gagne c'est grâce au joueur
quand on perd sa faute des coches rien à
voir absolument
rien à voir mais c'est vrai que
Pierre aladi alors je suis pas tout à
fait je veux juste revenir parce que on
a on a quand même par exemple le Racing
au rugby il faut un petit peu ce système
de chauffe il faut ce petit système de
chaud au sein même des matchs qui prend
et qui prend bien sauf que
malheureusement pour c'est le serpent
qui sont dans laquelle pour le football
américain parce que pour faire ça il
faut des moyens pour avoir des moyens et
il faut que ce que il faut des
licenciers il faut que ce soit connu et
voilà on a rien sans rien alors mise à
part un fanatique qui arrive avec un
gros budget et qui dit moi je veux
révolutionner
le football américain en France et je
vois pas comment simplement en
participant et en développant comme ça
par la base je crois pas que ça encore
une fois c'est une grosse différence de
culture les Templiers ils ont quand même
quelques pom-pom girls cheerleaders
maintenant je crois je crois qu'on dit
ça c'est
bien c'est un début on va dire mais ça
bon girl c'est les pom-pom girl c'est
c'est pas des gros
du des gros cachets
c'est pas le spectacle c'est pas le
spectacle il faut quand même des moyens
mais le problème c'est ça c'est pour
avoir les moyens il faut être connu il
faut il faut pouvoir développer donc
c'est que c'est compliqué c'est vraiment
très compliqué pour eux
particulières ils sont passés de 25000 à
18 licenciés après le covid avant le
colis de 25000 après covid 18000 il y a
un petit peu de mieux on va dire en
France il y a quelques matchs qui sont
diffusés mais c'est pas sur une grosse
plateforme c'est sur la plateforme sport
en France qui est mis en il me semble
par il me semble que c'est par le Comité
Olympique et Sportif Français cette
plateforme donc il y a un tout petit peu
mieux maintenant en Europe bah le
football américain souffre d'un sérieux
concurrent face qui est le football tout
court le soccer de l'autre côté bah
c'est le soccer et aussi en minorité par
rapport au football américain mais en
Europe le sport roi il y a des il y a il
y a le rugby aussi bien sûr mais il y a
aussi le football forcément il y a une
grosse concurrence qui est qui est
difficile de battre qui sera impossible
de battre et bien justement on va parler
soccer maintenant l'affaire fait grand
bruit ces derniers jours le PSG pour
équité le Parc des Princes en effet un
bras de fer oppose la mairie de Paris
qui ne veut pas vendre la structure aux
propriétaires catharien qui veulent
quant à eux acheter et moderniser les
lieux il y en a un qui a sauté sur
l'occasion c'est Carlo livre le député
de la douzième circonscription des
emails à poster un montage photo d'un
stade avec le logo du Paris
Saint-Germain avec le commentaire et
alors ce tweet montre qu'il est disposé
accueillir le PSG dans les Yvelines
sûrement dans sa circonscription vers
Poissy les dirigeants parisiens
vous êtes au club donc envisager de
partir ailleurs ça devient une nécessité
pour le Paris Saint-Germain et il n'y a
pas non plus de foncier on va dire
beaucoup de fonciers disponibles en
Île-de-France donc envisager de partir à
Poissy ça pourrait être une bonne
solution vous l'avez rappelé il y a ce
centre d'entraînement du Paris
Saint-Germain qui sera construit à
Poissy donc ce serait peut-être une
juste logique de voir le terrain du PSG
peut-être s'implanter à proximité de ce
son d'entraînement peut-être au sein du
futur centre d'entraînement ça
s'assemble plutôt plutôt compliqué non
moi pour moi c'est dans la logique des
choses le PSG pour ma part si je parle
en tant qu'amoureux de football doit
rester au Parc des Princes maintenant
s'il doit quitter le Parc des Princes
par par nécessité Poissy pour moi ça
pourrait être une bonne destination
Philippe
non moi le PSG c'est c'est le Parc des
Princes voilà on parle beaucoup de on a
parlé beaucoup du Stade de France déjà
quand le temps que si si bien sûr il
reste là il faudra penser aussi à le
voilà on c'est difficile parce que le
périph passe en dessous voire surmonter
c'est difficile parce que il y a tout
autour les riverains c'est quand même
c'est quand même difficile
en plus si on le vend au Qataris ça
risque de changer ce sera plus Parc des
Princes ce sera le naiming c'est la mode
donc ce sera ce sera un autre un autre
nom là j'ai entendu encore ce matin il y
a Joinville qui voudrait il y a
plusieurs villes même sur le comment sur
ils ont même parlé du stade Bobin à côté
même comme il y a l'hippodrome à côté ce
serait encore possible mais il va
falloir du temps avant déjà s'il faut
construire il va falloir déjà du temps
de construire et puis les supporters ne
sont pas du tout ne sont pas du tout
d'accord donc voilà
qui vous a convaincu aussi
libre plutôt Philippe même si même si
l'acronyme pouvait rester le Poissy
Saint-Germain ça marche un petit peu
moins bien dans des plaises au début du
livre et au-delà au-delà du Parc des
Princes c'est mine de rien c'est quand
même c'est quand même là aussi une
affaire de gaming le Paris Saint-Germain
c'est à Paris et
certes il y a une querelle de grosses ou
on en a parlé en fin d'année dernière ou
effectivement les propositions sont sont
diamétralement opposées entre les
propositions de la mairie et les
propositions du PSG bon c'est
négociation à couteau tiret depuis
quelques temps
et voilà et par présenter mais en
l'occurrence c'est c'est vraiment
l'identité même de Paris qui s'inscrit
qui s'inscrit à Paris donc c'est même
pas forcément de débats ils sont déjà
ils délocalisent déjà depuis des années
et des années à Saint-Germain-en et puis
bientôt maintenant à Poissy sur les 102
le centre d'entraînement ils vont avoir
l'espace pour pouvoir progresser et
pouvoir justement s'entraîner et passer
des caps on l'espère même déjà gagner la
Ligue des Champions le plus rapidement
possible
il y a aussi une aussi une affaire de
timing comme un peu comme pour Yoka en
disant là il y a à la fois le temps qui
nous sépare des élections municipales
avec peut-être une issue un peu
différente et des négociations
différentes à partir de 2026 et puis le
temps qui presse aussi pour pour Paris
pour gagner des trophées avec sa dream
team actuel on sait que Mbappé ne sera
pas ne sera pas éternel actuellement
neymar et pas dans son dans son plus
grand jour mais si il est plutôt il est
champion du monde mais il est il est il
est là aussi en fin de carrière donc
voilà donc le temps presse donc le temps
presse et actuellement il me semble plus
judicieux d'essayer de trouver une issue
dans cette dans cette négociation au
Parc des Princes là où tout s'est
inscrit à Paris plutôt que d'aller
imaginer
l'emmener ailleurs et devenir le Poissy
Saint-Germain normalement il y a un
contrôle jusqu'en 2043 entre le PSG
l'Amérique Paris bon pour préciser genre
parce que le ouais c'est ça vous faites
bien de dire parce que là le le PSG il
fallait qatars les Qataris pardon non
pas trop le choix dans la date parce que
c'est un ils sont ils sont unis par un
bail en phytéotique et le problème de de
ce bail alors ce que je comprends pas
par contre c'est qu'ils veulent ils
veulent acheter pour pour faire pour
faire des modifications mais je suis pas
je suis pas juridique mais ils ont le
droit c'est d'ailleurs le le la
différence qu'il y a entre ce bail là et
un bail un bail commercial c'est qu'ils
ont le droit de faire ce qu'ils veulent
au même titre qu'un propriétaire donc je
pense que c'est pas plus spécialement
parce que ça leur interdit de faire de
faire la modifications je pense plus que
au niveau des c'est plus une
valorisation de leurs actifs plutôt que
que racheter pour être pour pouvoir
faire une modifications qui veulent ça
c'est pour moi c'est une fausse idée
pour moi je pense que ce ben ce format
là combien très bien il faut que ça
reste à Paris parce que c'est le Paris
Saint-Germain et que c'est historique le
Parc des Princes on va pas le rebaptiser
il y a tout à fait raison Philippe un
ennemi à la con un ennemi qui serait pas
de qui serait pas bien
ça va échappé je monte mais ce sont
passionné en tout cas pour moi voilà
donc ça doit rester à Paris Paris
Saint-Germain c'est Paris et les autres
ils ont quand ils ont lancé l'argent
l'économie du foot actuel on ne peut pas
faire sans de stade de propriété c'est
le modèle qui va se déployer qui s'est
déjà déployé on le voit en Angleterre en
France ça commence aussi à l'idée
commence à faire son pas les grandes
équipes on leur rendors ça mais un club
se valorise aussi par un stade de
propriété et je pense pas que les
Qataris vont être éternel aussi le Paris
Saint-Germain et un jour ils vont
vouloir revendre le PSG et s'ils n'ont
pas de stade forcément la valeur du PSG
sera valorisation des actifs ce n'est
pas forcément pour toujours comme le
Paris-Nice dans les Yvelines on va
terminer par une information à insolite
elle concerne un jour de l'équipe de
France qui a été en partie formé dans
les Yvelines à Clairefontaine et qui a
marqué 3 buts en finale de la dernière
Coupe du Monde est-ce que vous voyez qui
je veux parler éventuellement Michel
platine
alors Killian Mbappé devenu une star
planétaire on le sait tous mais
médiatisation qui a aussi touché le
Pérou cette année en 2022 230 bébé ont
été prénommés Mbappé par leurs parents
et notamment pendant ou après la Coupe
du monde les Péruviens sont apparemment
friands de noms sur l'actualité il y a
eu 267 Messi 176 Argentina le prénom
Antoine Griezmann a été donné à 86
enfants du côté des filles 551 bébé ont
été baptisés Rennes Elisabeth et est-ce
que voilà est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez de cette actualité insolite
super est-ce que vous pourriez prélever
votre fils Kylian Mbappé Philippe c'est
pas le Pérou pour moi
déjà quand on donne des prénoms des
prénoms on se dit tiens Kevin par
exemple comme moi j'ai deux clients donc
tout ça je veux dire voilà c'est des
fois on dit tiens c'est par rapport à un
sportif ou un artiste ou un chanteur ou
comme ça mais là là non voilà
bien sûr des dons de marque de voiture
venez juste le prénom de son idole c'est
un Killian pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
mais Killian Mbappé en prénom je pense
que c'est compliqué à apporter reine
Élisabeth alors j'en parle j'en parle
même pas après Messi
il a une aura mondiale ça y est alors il
l'avait déjà mais que il inspire des
générations et d'inspirer des
générations à venir visiblement
alors c'est déjà la fin de cette
émission on va terminer comme d'habitude
par une citation aujourd'hui je vous
propose une citation de Mike Tyson
ancien boxeur professionnel les gens que
tu croises quand tu montes vers les
sommets tu peux les recroiser quand tu
descends vers l'enfer je vous laisse
méditer sur cette phrase à bientôt sur
TV 78
[Musique]